for several months now president trump
has been claiming that he has lost three
to five
billion dollars from the presidency
given trump's history of overestimating
and exaggerating
you would think that this would be much
higher than he actually lost
but this time it's actually quite
comparable as forbes estimates he has
lost 2.4 billion dollars
since his bid for the presidency as his
net worth has dropped from 4.5 billion
in 2015
to 2.1 billion right now so why has
trump lost over
half his wealth
well starting off trump's bid for the
presidency
has no doubt polarized the country this
has led to many people boycotting the
trump organization
and the thing is that this boycott
doesn't just originate from democrats
but republicans as well sure democrats
may choose to not
stay at a trump hotel to essentially
vote with their dollars
and this is completely fine and to be
expected
however the problem is worsened when
republicans don't want to use any of
their facilities
either this isn't because they don't
want to support it from business
but because they rather not be judged
for supporting trump
the fact that the core of his real
estate is located in the heart of new
york and chicago
which are overwhelmingly blue states
doesn't help much either
so his run has significantly impacted
his top line
reducing his customers to largely just
outward trump supporters
moving on his run for the presidency has
introduced an influx of media
as well as security at all of his
locations even if you don't mind staying
at a trump hotel
or using one of his country clubs
despite what others might think of you
you might still stay away to avoid the
media as well as titan security
a news team literally camps out on the
first floor of trump tower
and a lot of people don't want to deal
with that many of trump's country club
members
have also pointed out that the use of
metal detectors as well as bomb sniffing
dogs
has skyrocketed now this makes sense
but again the average person does not
want to be involved in this friction
again hurting his top line next up since
taking office
trump has pledged to not expand
internationally during his time in
office in order to reduce any opposing
interests that may arise
as a result his international portfolio
has remained stagnant for nearly four
years at this point
his children have made one international
deal during trump's time in
office which was selling off a piece of
land in the dominican republic
for 3.2 million this is technically a
violation of his no international deals
pledge
but really it's not that big of a deal
when you consider how small of a
percentage
it is within his vast fortune and that
brings me into my next point
which is the transfer of management
completely away from trump to his
children
now many of his children already held
high level management positions
so it wasn't that big of a transition on
top of this
his children couldn't have really done
much to avoid the aforementioned cuts in
revenue
however one thing to note is that his
children do have a much more risk
adverse management style
compared to trump instead of expanding
the trump empire across the u.s
his children have focused their efforts
on making their previous investments
more stable
in the first three years of trump's
presidency his children have sold off
110 million dollars worth of real estate
they have used these funds to pay off
debt and fund money losing properties to
avoid taking on more debt
this heavy focus on simply maintaining
their properties and reducing their debt
load
has put expansion at nearly a standstill
the only purchase they made within the
same time period
was a 18.5 million dollar mansion they
bought from their aunt
or trump's older sister marianne though
paying off debt is not a bad thing per
se
this does explain a lack of growth in
trump's portfolio
speaking of a lack of growth many of the
states that his hotels are located in
have seen a lack of growth not just that
but they have topped a list of fastest
shrinking states in the u.s
with new york taking first place and
illinois taking a second place
this is largely due to very high living
expenses
as well as sky high tax rates people
moving out itself is not a negative
as trump's hotels rely on visitors to
the cities as opposed to the people
living there
however as people move out of the states
so do the companies
one of the primary reasons many
companies put up with high taxes and
harsh business policies
in places like california and new york
is because of the talent pool in the
area
but when this is dwindling there is no
reason for them to stay any longer
and a reduction of companies in the area
directly reduces the number of business
travelers coming to the area
business travelers make up 40 of total
hotel guests
and the thing is they likely make for
the majority of the revenue
for instance business travelers only
make up 12
of air travelers however they make up
for 75
of airlines profits this is because they
are more likely to make last-minute
bookings
be willing to pay more for non-stop
flights and of course
book business and first-class seats
similarly
it's likely that business travelers book
last minute hotels
are willing to pay more for hotels
closest central city
and book more expensive rooms themselves
so
though business travelers make up 40
reservations
it's likely they make up for the
majority of the profit and with
businesses leaving the area
this is likely to have a large impact on
the bottom line of airlines
and hotels in the area so a polarization
of many customers
a reduction in quality of customers
experiences a lack of expansion
internationally and domestically
as well as geographical trends have been
the leading factors in the devaluation
of the trump empire
as these account for 1.4 billion in
losses
the last billion comes from the pandemic
which is really quite self-explanatory
most if not all of trump's businesses
are hotels
casinos or country clubs and virtually
no one is traveling or hitting the
casinos
so it's no wonder they're hurting
similarly
the businesses of many country club
members may also be hurting
so they might withdraw from the country
club and
that's how trump lost over half his
wealth he'll likely recover a good
amount as we come out of the pandemic
but if he gets reelected it's likely
that this overall downward trend will
continue
now a lot of people are likely going to
be ecstatic
citing that he deserves to lose his
money for the disservice he has done for
the country
while others will respect him even more
classifying the laws as a noble
sacrifice
from good old donald j trump personally
i don't think we should be particularly
happy at a president's misfortune
but that's just what i think if you guys
like the depth of this analysis
drop a like and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you